I'm back with some real interesting
information there's a very common keto
friendly ingredient that could be
stopping your weight loss
we know that keto is low carb right we
know that you need to cut out the sugars
we know we need to cut out the grains
but we're going to talk about green oils
or specifically seed oils and a nice way
of saying it would be vegetable oils
which is really not vegetable oil
because you're not taking the oil from
the vegetable you're taking it from the
seed of the plant okay that's a lot
different what's the problem the problem
is omega-6 fats okay highly inflammatory
it triggers insulin resistance just as
bad as sugar or refined grains I mean if
you even look at the past from 1970 to
present we had an increase of sugar but
we had a much more massive spike of
vegetable oils not to mention the soy
oil the cottonseed oil canola oil and
corn oil are all GMO so that's a
compounded effect that I don't want to
get into at this point but we also have
safflower oil and sunflower oil almond
flour and peanut butter are all higher
in omega-6
now I'm not saying you can't have some
of these but you want to balance it out
with your omega-3 an average person in
America has 15 times more omega-6 than
omega-3 and they're consuming 45 grams
of omega-6 fats every single day that's
ten point eight teaspoons of that oil
that is crazy too high
here's another problem that goes beyond
the inflammation and insulin resistance
the half-life for some of these oils are
between six hundred and six hundred
eighty days in other words they're not
used as fuel they get stuck in the body
and the cell membranes they clog up the
liver they clog up the brain even
some of these foods are not ketogenic
some are these are the top sources
omega-6 fats number one chicken and you
realize that chicken has very high
levels of omega-6 fatty acids number two
would be grain deserts of course if
you're in Quito you're not going to be
doing that but that's very high in
omega-6 salad dressings this is one that
you may be doing and not even knowing
it's very high in omega-6 and even
though there might not be any sugar in
it it's inflammatory and it can cause
and send resistance
what about chips potato chips corn chips
they're using these these oils right
here right omega 6 fatty acids nuts and
seeds are mainly omega-6 fatty acids now
I'm not saying you can't do nuts or
seeds I'm just saying you have to
balance this out with the omega-3 fatty
acids pizza of course that's omega-6
breads fries because you're going to be
using one of these oils right here and
of course pasta the definition of keto
is low carb it doesn't really emphasize
the type of fat that you should be
putting in your body you'll be much
healthier if you focus on cooking with
the coconut oil the butter and the
especially the olive oil and the avocado
oil if you're plateauing with keto you
may be consuming too many of these oils
right here or you're using too much
almond flour some people on keto get
inflamed when they consume almond flour
that could come from either the oxalates
or the omega-6 they get inflammation
when they do too much peanut butter with
these two I just recommend use these in
moderation you can even use some of
these but you're gonna have to offset it
with more omega-3 fatty acids it's kind
of debatable as far as the exact ratio
you need but if you're gonna do maybe a
three to one or even like a 1 to 1 ratio
for awhile till you get things balanced
out that might be a good idea so what
has more omega-3 fatty acids fish column
oil
fed beef and other animal products
walnuts and chia seed and Brussels
sprouts and other vegetables to have a
precursor to omega-3 it's a la this is
just so the reason why you need to do
the healthy version of keto if you're
new to my channel I put a link down
below but definitely do not put these in
your body limit these two right here and
possibly reduce these right here if you
have a problem with inflammation or
maybe you just plateaued and you want to
speed up the weight loss if you haven't
seen my other video on plateau I'm gonna
put it up right here check it out